there are 300 political prisoners in
Venezuela the country's political
prisoners and the National Assembly have
been awarded at the 2017 Sakharov Prize
for freedom of thought Parliament agrees
that there has been sufficient progress
in BRICS in negotiations paving the way
for Phase two of talks but there are
outstanding issues still to be resolved
such as the right of free movement for
UK citizens in EU countries top-ups to
attract young farmers to the industry
will arise to 50 percent of their basic
payment right all part of measures to
bolster farmers against risk and boost
bargaining power against supermarkets
more than 600,000 Rohingya have fled
were the UN calls an ethnic cleansing by
the Burmese authorities in Myanmar MEP s
have called for stronger sanctions to
bring an end to the atrocities a hundred
and forty-three politicians were
implicated in the enormous leak last
year MEP has pushed for open registers
effective whistleblower protection and
rules for intermediaries